Oil, Gas and Petrochemicals.
When oil wells get older, it becomes more difficult to pump oil efficiently,...
...as the pressure decreases.
The recovery of oil can be improved by using water injection.
It can be improved from 15 percent to as much as 50 percent.
Water injection wells are usually located at the periphery or edge of the field...
...and by forcing water below the accumulation,...
...the crude oil is pushed towards the producing wells near the center.
As well as raising the pressure in the wells,...
...water injection also keeps oil below its bubble point.
This is the point when gas can escape from the crude oil in great quantities...
...and is produced more than oil.
Before water is injected into a well though,...
...it must be treated to remove solids, bacteria and oxygen...
...that might cause damage or corrode the equipment.
Sea water can be used for injection on offshore platforms,...
...but it needs to be desalinated, to have the salt removed,...
...because untreated sea water can be highly corrosive.